Creating high-quality photorealistic materials
for light transport simulations typically
includes direct hands-on interaction with
a principled shader.
This means that the user has to tweak a large
number of material properties by hand, and
has to wait for a new image of it to be rendered
after each interaction.
This requires a fair bit expertise and the
best setups are often obtained through a lengthy
trial and error process.
To enhance this workflow, we present a learning-based
system for rapid mass-scale material synthesis.
First, the user is presented with a gallery
of materials and the assigned scores are shown
in the upper left.
Here, we learn the concept of glassy and transparent
materials.
By leaning on only a few tens of high-scoring
samples, our system is able to recommend many
new materials from the learned distributions.
The learning step typically takes a few seconds,
where the recommendations take negligible
time and can be done on a mass scale.
Then, these recommendations can be used to
populate a scene with materials.
Typically, each recommendation takes 40-60
seconds to render with global illumination,
which is clearly unacceptable for real-world
workflows for even mid-sized galleries.
In the next step, we propose a convolutional
neural network that is able to predict images
of these materials that are close to the ones
generated via global illumination, and takes
less than 3 milliseconds per image.
Sometimes a recommended material is close
the one envisioned by the user, but requires
a bit of fine-tuning.
To this end, we embed our high-dimensional
shader descriptors into an intuitive 2D latent
space where exploration and adjustments can
take place without any domain expertise.
However, this isn't very useful without additional
information because the user does not know
which regions offer useful material models
that are in line with their scores.
One of our key observations is that this latent
space technique can be combined with Gaussian
Process Regression to provide an intuitive
color coding of the expected preferences to
help highlighting the regions that may be
of interest.
Furthermore, our convolutional neural network
can also provide real-time predictions of
these images.
These predictions are close to indistinguishable
from the real rendered images and are generated
in real time.
Beyond the preference map, this neural network
also opens up the possibility of visualizing
the expected similarity of these new materials
to the one we seek to fine-tune.
By combining the preference and similarity
maps, we obtain a color coding that guides
the user in this latent space towards materials
that are both similar and have a high expected
score.
To accentuate the utility of our real-time
variant generation technique, we show a practical
case where one of the grape materials is almost
done, but requires a slight reduction in vividity.
This adjustment doesn't require any domain
expertise or direct interaction with a material
modeling system and can be done in real time.
In this example, we learn the concept of translucent
materials from only a handful of high-scoring
samples and generate a large amount of recommendations
from the learned distribution.
These recommendations can then be used to
populate a scene with relevant materials.
Here, we show the preference and similarity
maps of the learned translucent material space
and explore possible variants of an input
material.
These recommendations can be used for mass-scale
material synthesis, and the amount of variation
can be tweaked to suit the user's artistic
vision.
After assigning the appropriate materials,
displacements and other advanced effects can
be easily added to these materials.
We have also experimented with an extended,
more expressive version of our shader that
also includes procedural textured albedos
and displacements.
The following scenes were populated using
the material learning and recommendation and
latent space embedding steps.
We have proposed a system for mass-scale material
synthesis that is able to rapidly recommend
a broad range of new material models after
learning the user preferences from a modest
number of samples.
Beyond this pipeline, we also explored powerful
combinations of the three used learning algorithms,
thereby opening up the possibility of real-time
photorealistic material visualization, exploration
and fine-tuning in a 2D latent space.
We believe this feature set offers a useful
solution for rapid mass-scale material synthesis
for novice and expert users alike and hope
to see more exploratory works combining the
advantages of multiple state of the art learning
algorithms in the future.